hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
before we begin we want to cover a few
housekeeping items
for any common technical issues please
refer to the help widget located at the
bottom of your screen
this webinar was pre-recorded and is
being presented with a live q
a if you're tuning in for the initial
webcast you can submit questions via the
q a widget on the left side of your
screen
the researchers will be answering them
via the widget in real time
also stick around after the webinar for
the live q a
when the researchers will dive deeper on
popular questions asked
additional resources and links provided
from today's presentation
can be found in the resource list on the
right side of your screen
and an on-demand version of the webinar
will be available approximately one day
after the initial webcast
and can be accessed using the same
audience link that was sent to you
earlier
on-demand viewers will get to hear the
recorded version of the live q a
enjoy the webinar
hi i'm ben zorn and i'm going to be
talking about the next generation of
developer tools
for data programming my background is
that i'm a researcher in the research
and software engineering group inside
microsoft research the redmond lab
and my uh history focuses on
looking at problems related to
programming languages in particular
issues
related to reliability performance and
security
today i'm going to be focusing on a
different category of user in this case
when i say developer i'm not talking
about traditional professional
developers i'm talking about
developers who use computers to solve
problems
and i'll go into more detail with that
and when i talk about data programming
i'm not talking about writing code the
way we traditionally think about writing
code
i'm going to be focusing on the next
generation of uh
tools that allow people to use data and
convert it into useful
information and and ideas
so before i go into that let me give you
an outline of the talk i'm going to
start by
outlining briefly my notion of the
history both of the computers that we
use
and the tools we use to program them the
second part of the talk i'm going to
focus specifically on
issues related to people using
spreadsheets and why i talk about
spreadsheets is because fundamentally
i see spreadsheets as the prototype for
the kind of
very powerful tool that enables people
that aren't necessarily professional
developers to have very valuable
insights and and work with computers
to solve their problems and finally i'm
going to open up the discussion and look
more
more broadly at a whole class of
problems now that we're seeing
where people are using computers and
data together
to build new new kinds of experiences
new programs
and that that notion of using machine
learning using ai
is fundamental to the next generation of
applications
so let me let me start by doing a little
bit history i got my phd thesis in 1989
and it was focused on
the performance of garbage collection
which is a technique in programming
languages
and as as much as it was about software
and
software tools and algorithms in fact a
lot of my thesis actually
involved data so i was measuring what
the performance of these
this particular approach to garbage
collection and
i was looking at the trends i was
looking for patterns that i saw in the
data
to understand what insights i could get
and this is back in 1989 and the tools i
had were quite primitive but
you can see right at the beginning of my
career i really was focused
on extracting information from data
now 10 years later i was at microsoft
research this is building nine
on the microsoft research campus it was
a great building uh recently torn down
um but what what else was true in 1999
well
first of all you can look at the
computers that we were using and you
know
there's a desktop uh obviously laptop
the
the big computers the big iron were
things like the super computers the
ascii
blue mountain super computer and in 1998
it had 6000 processors
and it was approximately estimated to
have about
three teraflops of performance which at
the time was amazing
what kind of tools did people use to
program these computers
well of course you know as is familiar
we knew even back then we had visual
studio and it was a very powerful tool
and allowed you to
actually build components using visual
basic cetera that's one of the great
advantages that the pc market created
was its opportunity for many people to
participate to generate applications et
cetera
um we had new languages languages like
java
languages like javascript where if
you're just starting to show up
in the market you can see the history
here you know
the ecmascript the standard around
javascript was created in 1998
now let's look a little bit at data
science tools these are tools that
people
working with extracting insights from
data were using
at that time and of course one of the
really powerful tools at the time
was excel and this is an example of
excel 95.
there were other tools on the horizon
they weren't really widely used but they
were available
one of them was a language called s
which was developed at bell labs
and at the time it was really the first
effort to try to focus on helping people
have very specific problems around
reasoning about data doing statistical
analysis of data and it was at the time
you probably never heard of it but in
fact
it was it was the genesis that actually
led to the r language the
the successor um likewise python was an
early development um
uh one of the major releases of python
occurred in about 2000
and it really was just starting to be
used
more broadly than by a narrow group of
people
okay so let's fast forward 20 years uh
this is now last year
microsoft research has moved now we're
in building 99 building 99
a beautiful facility um one of the
things that we see now
in the in the current generation of
computers is just an enormous variety in
the kinds of computers that we have
okay so it used to be desktops laptops
now it's we have
you know we have our doorbell as a
computer almost everything we touch
these days
has a computer embedded in it and that
really totally changes the kinds of
things we do with computers
um one of the things to look at with
this with this slide is
the amount of compute power that we have
in our hands now things like
uh the your apple iphone the next
generation estimated 0.7 teraflops so
that's a quarter of that ascii super
computer we talked about
in 1999 the xbox one six teraflops
that's two times so every one of your
xbox one x has
twice as much compute power as that
giant computer that we had back in 1999
and you know amazingly even your car the
the estimate for the the
nvidia processor in the current
generation of cars
is 30 teraflops 10 times the the
performance of
uh what you had in the ascii super
computer but but
this focus on the devices we have right
now misses totally misses
an entire generation of change that
we've seen and that's
the the cloud the advent of cloud
computing so as much as those are
amazing devices
if you look at this this is a picture of
the the uh microsoft
quincy data center uh taken from a talk
by mark russinovich
and it shows the scale of the of the
compute power now that we have
at our disposal for things like natural
language understanding for things like
search etc
and and the the the advent of the cloud
brings an enormous amount of
resources both compute storage and
networking into the hands of almost
anyone that wants to use it
and so this is a total revolution in the
capabilities of the computers we have
and the kinds of problems we try to
solve with them likewise the tools that
developers use
to to leverage to harness this power or
have also evolved
and some of these things are still quite
familiar so for example we have visual
studio
we have visual studio code both very
valuable both
widely used familiar but we also have a
whole new generation of tools that
really has changed the game with respect
to software developers
in particular we have github github is a
great way to bring together many many
different
developers to share to uh to exchange to
provide insights back and forth um it's
an it's a revolution in the way people
share
their experience around developing code
likewise we have now tools because we
have all the cloud
clouds and cloud computing we have all
the tools around harnessing the cloud
and so if you look
if you go to the azure website and you
start looking at all the things that you
can just easily drag and drop and create
uh new cloud instances it's it's it's a
very powerful tool set it allows people
to build systems to test them to uh
deploy them etc
with just a touch of a button and
finally on top of that cloud computing
infrastructure now we have the notion of
containers and the ability to
to package our software uh instances our
software systems into larger software
systems
and deploy them just with a touch of a
button and so we have tools like
kubernetes around that
so the major takeaway here is that cloud
computing really has
changed the game both in terms of what
computers are available and how people
use them
now let's revisit as i mentioned we're
talking about data programming data
programmers
let's look at what data scientists have
for tools so one of the great things
that
programs have today for for data is
excel in fact if you look carefully
the ex the interface for excel looks
very similar to what we had
20 years ago and one of the takeaways
here is that that's a positive thing in
the sense that
it's a stable well understood framing of
what you need
to understand data but on the negative
the the
as as i've shown many many of these
things in the in the world of computing
have evolved dramatically
and the question becomes how have the
tools that we use to understand data
evolved in the same way so for example
we have rstudio
s evolved into the language r which is
an open source implementation of s
and r studio is a developer experience
that allows you to write code in r
and understand it similarly around
python we have a notion of notebooks
which is
which is really an evolution of the
concept of literate program where we
have a sequence of
steps that that involve actually getting
information processing it etc
coming to a conclusion and these
notebooks capture those steps in a way
that they can be shared
which is also very valuable but one of
the things we hear when we talk to data
scientists
is that all the regulars all the stuff
that regular developers
uh take for granted you don't have when
you move into a notebook environment you
don't have the same kinds of
high-powered capabilities say kubernetes
or github etc
when you're trying to do data science
and i'll drill down on that on that
point a little more in just a minute
but let me recap the key insight here is
that
in 20 years we've seen enormous changes
in the way that computers
exist you know how they how the
computers work how much power they have
and how people programming and yet even
though even though almost all the future
of computing
depends on understanding capturing
understanding and
taking value out of data we the tools
that we have to understand that data to
work for that data have not evolved at
the same rate
so we have all this computation we have
all this ability
to think about how we might solve really
hard problems using aiml etc but the
tools that we have to do that task
are still not up to the task
and so this the really my my talk is a
call to action
it's a call to action to the community
the developer community the professional
development community to the
software engineering community to think
about these a broader view of who is a
developer
so traditionally we think about pro devs
professional developers people who
write write c code or c plus plus code
or java for a living
but i want to think about growth
developers these are developers who are
not the traditional c
plus plus uh et cetera they're people
whose job it is to take data
and get insights we often call them data
scientists i like to think of them as
as a different class of developer
there's people who want to get a job
done they use a computer to solve that
problem
they have to answer questions you know
when can i retire
how effective is this drug what's the
best crop to plant in the soil these are
all fundamental questions
and i don't want to have to be able to
be a c plus programmer to answer them
and this is this is why i'm calling on
the software engineering community
to take those individuals who are trying
to answer those questions as a priority
to not focus solely on the professional
developers but to expand the view of who
a developer is
and take into those and take into
account those people and you know you
can ask well why why should we do that
well here's the big answer because there
are 750 million excel users
okay so instead of the 50 or you know 10
million
professional developers we're talking
about orders of magnitude more people
with a much broader view of what their
problems are trying to solve
and i'll and i'll talk to that at the
end of the talk but fundamentally you
know the ambition
for what we can do with computers has
gone up enormously
and what we need to do is empower the
people who can achieve those
achieve those goals reach that ambition
with the right tools
okay so uh that's mostly my
sort of aside about history let me just
say one other thing about history um
so fundamentally when we think about
software engineering we think about the
process of helping developers
we really focus on the code so
historically what that means
is that we write code we we say hey is
this code right is that wrong
um and you know we can see that in some
of the early works like for example the
class
veer uh you know a very famous uh
programming language designer and
a spokesperson about software um had a
book called algorithms plus data
structures equals programs
and let me just challenge that for you
know directly i personally feel like
he's missing an enormous part of what of
what programming and what
and what building applications is and
that's the data we can't have
useful things without the data and i
think what we've seen in the history you
know the 30 or 40 years since this book
was written is
the data makes enormous amount of
difference in terms of what the ambition
that we have
and the kinds of ways that we we think
about building software
so let me step back and now focus a
little bit more directly on spreadsheets
you know i made i sort of made a joke
about how spreadsheets you know in 1999
and spreadsheets today are kind of the
same
and that's that's true on the surface
but of course it's not true
when you dig down for example um you
know spreadsheets down multi-platform
you can go to any you know in particular
excel you can go to any any platform and
get a spreadsheet and it works just the
way you expect there's there's things
like collaboration very powerful
capability multiple people working
together in the same document
here's inside microsoft research we've
done some innovative things to empower
people using spreadsheets and this is
focused
particularly again on people who are not
developers who wouldn't who don't know
how to write the code
but who need the power of the computer
to help them so for example there's a
capability in excel 2013 and later
called flash fill that allows you to do
programming by example
where i can do a string edit i can
extract from a string like the gym.smith
just the the company or the last name
show an example of that
and then the computer inside excel will
actually automatically
determine a program that will help me
complete that task for all the other
uh all the other uh strings in the in
the email column
so that ability to program by example is
very powerful because again
it enables many more people who couldn't
write the code
to do that transformation to get the
value of it just by showing examples
um more recently one of the things
that's been added to excel is rich data
types so instead of
uh just numbers and strings we actually
have you know uh records in this case
financial records etc so
so these tools have evolved but what i'm
going to point out in the next section
is that there's still a tremendous
amount of opportunity here we're not
done
without evolution of tools to help
people with data
so let me focus specifically on
spreadsheets because
they're so widely used on the one hand
and they're also
used for very important decisions okay
and i'll highlight this so this
this uh news article from uh was it 2013
uh
uh talks about a problem it's called the
london whale
who is a traitor for morgan stanley he
basically made a bad
trade based on a single cell in a
spreadsheet having the wrong formula
and that trade in particular led to
about a nine billion dollar loss so one
spreadsheet cell with one error
nine billion dollars now if that isn't a
reason to
try to find bugs in spreadsheets i can't
think of another one but that's not the
only example of this situation
there there are a number you can look on
the web there are a number of cases
where
errors in spreadsheets resulted in bad
decisions in
money lost in particular here's here's a
one that hits home
um it was discovered a couple years ago
that in fact
biologists have been using spreadsheets
excel spreadsheets to store
information about gene sequences and
it's a very common practice to have the
spreadsheet accompany the paper
and uh some biologists started looking
at these these spreadsheets and realized
that
uh there had been an automatic
conversion from the gene names
like one sept it turns out is the name
of a gene into a calendar
into a into a date and this had not been
discovered
so about 20 percent of all the data in
some of these files was actually
incorrect and had been
incorrectly transformed so there's many
cases where uh people use spreadsheets
they get a result that they didn't
expect and we'd like to help them with
that
so how is it so so first of all we know
that there are you can build tools to
help software developers so certainly we
should be able to help
build tools to help spreadsheets users
as well
but what are the challenges why is it so
much harder to
help people who work with spreadsheets
than it is to help people who write code
and let me try to illustrate that with
with an example
of a file so one of the things that's
very different about spreadsheets is
that it combines many aspects that you
know usually are separate as i mentioned
with code
you know often developers think about
the code separate from the data the data
somewhere over here
they work on the code in the case of
spreadsheets what you have is you've got
a mix
you've got formulas so you know often
values and spreadsheets are computed and
i'll show you in just just a minute
how you can actually see which things
are computed which aren't and other
things which are just
data that comes in so it's a combination
of code and data
but what's really unique about
spreadsheets it's totally different than
the normal software normal code
is that there's also a layer of
presentation so the person who created
the spreadsheet
not only thought about the code in the
data they also were trying to
communicate something to somebody else
who was going to look at this sheet
so they they they add extra lines or
they underline
or they make a make a row bold all their
ad natural language help you understand
it
and these are aspects of understanding
software that traditional software
analysis
does not focus on at all okay so this is
a new challenge
so let me just highlight the differences
between trying to find bugs in software
and in code
and trying to find bugs and spreadsheets
so often i mean never with spreadsheets
do you have a specification
you don't have somebody saying you know
this value should always be greater than
zero
you don't have tests there's no notion
of a unit test for a spreadsheet
you have a very limited type system
relative to a program so a program you
can create your own types
you can do type checking et cetera in
spreadsheets
often the values are just values it's
like there's a number
uh it's is it euros is it dollars well
there might be formatting
but there's no underlying system that
tells you oh you're about to add
a dollar to a euro which would be an
incorrect thing to do one of the things
about spreadsheets is that
it is the degree to which spatial
relations matter and so people
looking at them understand that they
understand how something at the bottom
of a column probably relates to the
things above it
um of course you don't have that same
notion in software
um and again as we focused you know from
the beginning of the talk really we're
talking about individuals who don't have
the traditional software development
background they don't have the same
experience
writing code debugging testing etc
and you know just to sort of highlight
one of the challenges is like even
knowing
what data goes with what is a challenge
so in spreadsheets you have a free form
approach
and so as a result even knowing what the
boundaries of say a table are
or whether these two things are related
to each other because they're in the
same table
or they're separate is not it's not a
solid problem it's not
explicit in the document so i'm going to
talk about two methods that i personally
have worked on
to think about how we can help
developers with spreadsheets and they're
they involve two projects independent
approaches to solving this problem
the first approach uses statistics and
it's a tool called excellent
and we call it excellent because lint is
a traditional tool that was used to find
software bugs and so excellent is a is a
way to find
bugs and spreadsheets and the the method
for excellent
that distinguishes it is the notion that
it it doesn't use a complex machine
learning model it just uses a notion of
regularity and statistics
to try to understand anomalies and
spreadsheets
so instead of talking about it in the
abstract let's go to an example
okay so this is a spreadsheet from a
corpus a public domain corpus
um it's basically not a real spreadsheet
in the sense that it's it looks like
some employee payroll
um and you know it's it you know it was
on the web somewhere uh somebody got it
um and you can immediately see in it you
know there's information that a human
can glean
um so these are probably people the
names of people
um you know there's some calculation
about say their taxes
or how much they get how much they take
home there's information about how many
hours they worked et cetera
um one thing is it's not obvious in this
view which is called the value view of
the spreadsheet
which values are computed and which ones
are formula are
are just raw data so you know the the
number of hours works is probably raw
data
but the total hours that doesn't seem
like that's a that's a
data that should be computed from these
other values and so how do we know that
well
you can go to individual cells and see
if it's being computed with a formula
but one of the tricks is that there's a
method uh
there's a there's a view inside excel
called the formula view
that actually opens up every cell and
shows you the formula instead of the
value being computed it shows the
formula used to compute it
and this view gives you more insight
into the structure because now you see
okay all these values are being computed
these are inputs
they're just you know the hourly rate um
and then some
some cases you start asking well these
are being well this is this cell
times 0.15 but hey you know why is this
one different
there's something going on here and uh
what we've done with excellent
so let me change that view back so again
you wouldn't notice that if you uh
if you didn't have that other view right
but but what we did with excellent we
said
there are patterns and we're going to
look for those patterns statistically
so if we type reveal structure on the
sheet um
all of a sudden we see some colors and
this is going to tell us something about
the sheet
and it immediately makes certain certain
relations more obvious
and so in particular let me just walk
through what some of these colors mean
there's two distinguished colors on this
on the sheet uh
gray and and yellow gray is a data value
so there's no formula being used to
compute these values
and the thing with gray is it means that
this is data that
is somehow being used by some other
formula in the sheet so it's it's kind
of being used it's in
it's it's consumed um the thing about
the yellow values is that those are
values
that are just there there's no there's
nothing else that uses them
and you and you might ask well why are
these even here well they must be there
to help
somebody who's looking at the sheet
because it's not you know not feeding
into any formulas
and so um that's one one aspect and that
helps you understand a little bit more
about
how the values flow the other thing that
to talk about is the colors and what
happens with the colors is
uh excellent uses a different color to
highlight
different formula patterns and so you
know the the formulas here
are being are different than the
formulas here are different than the
formulas here it doesn't say exactly how
they're different it just says that
they're different
now what uh so immediately there's some
things that come
you know sort of pop out like this cell
here is gray which means
it's a data value all the cells below it
are actually red
so this cell is probably incorrect and
in fact what we find
uh it's not even competing the correct
value so in this case we've got a cell
that should be
computed as not one of the things that
excellent points out is
if i go here is it will show us a case
where
again this whole column is being
computed by one one formula
but this this one cell is being computed
by a different formula
so again there's there's a mismatch here
and uh what we're doing with this
suspicious
essentially what we call suspicious
ranges is highlighting where on the
sheet
uh there are there are inconsistencies
that a human should probably pay
attention to
so that's our that's the approach of
excellent defining uh bugs and
spreadsheets it's both using the visual
system of human
to find patterns that seem irregular and
to understand the overall organization
of the sheet
and to take advantage of certain uh
statistical analyses to highlight
anomalies that we think are particularly
important
okay so that's excellent as i mentioned
basically the focus here is going to be
on two different techniques
to think about finding bugs and i've
already mentioned excellent
let me talk about the second technique
uh which is
a more uh let's see uh
a more complex and uh and at this point
a little bit less mature approach to
finding the same kinds of problems
and this approach is to use neural
networks is to reason about the contents
of the spreadsheet
by training a neural network uh to to
recognize patterns and to identify
cases where the patterns where the where
the the sheet breaks the pattern
and you know just as inspiration you can
think about
you know all the work on understanding
images and saying look we know
where the faces are in an image we have
techniques algorithmic techniques based
on convolutional neural networks
that will tell you what you know where
the where the people are where the faces
are
and so the our question was can you
apply a similar kind of approach
to recognizing aspects of spreadsheets
that you want to
you want to highlight and and the the
first work we did in this space is a
project called melford
and the idea here was to find cells in
sheets individual cells
for which the pattern is broken and we
think that it should
be this cell for example shouldn't be a
value which it is like it's not this is
a formula
this should also be a formula because
the the column header says total
and so you would imagine this value here
is the sum of these
so instead of being just a number it
should actually be a formula like sum
right here and so our our question was
can we train a neural network
to recognize irregularities like this
and highlight them for the user
now i'm not going to talk about the
melford project i'm going to talk about
another project we've done which is um
you know has some elements of this
and i'm going to use this project which
we call jira to think about
how we build the software that actually
allows us to
find these to do this kind of analysis
and this is going to
flow into the final part of my talk
where i'm going to focus on
what the challenges are of building any
software that incorporates ai
neural network techniques so let's talk
about a separate problem
which is a more of a core problem
instead of a an end
an end uh application it's more of a
understanding structure and the problem
i'm going to talk about is
how do you find tables on a given sheet
now
you might think well every sheet is a
table it's just one table
but in fact if you look at the way that
sheets are organized in fact
often you see multiple tables on a sheet
so in this case you can see here's a
header
a bunch of column headers and here's
some values and here's a separate header
and different and different values and
these are independent things
and however for whatever reason the
person who created the sheet
intended for them to be separate and and
to be looked at differently
so for example if you're going to
generate a chart from this data
you probably don't want to combine these
two you probably want to pick one of
these
and then create a chart and that's
that's why finding the tables finding
where the tables are is quite important
now you might think okay well couldn't
you just write an algorithm that you
know
tries to find the table some kind of
heuristics looks for
i don't know um cells that are have
value like numbers in them and
but you can see this this example really
breaks a lot of rules like there's empty
columns
right and uh you know there's is you
could ask well is this
is this part of the table below it or
not uh so heuristics in general are not
a good strategy we in fact built
uh some heuristics and found that they
weren't very uh very good at finding the
actual tables
um now so this opens the question well
what can we
what we can can we how do we solve this
problem with machine learning
and one of the traditional aspects of
machine learning is you have to train
so the notion is you build a model which
tries to predict things
and you have to train that model with
data so you have to have actual labeled
data
to train the model and a challenge that
we find in this particular space is
often when you think about say natural
language understanding or image
processing
the training involves hundreds of
thousands of labeled samples
that are used to train the network and
in our case we didn't have a hundred
thousand samples of
of sheets where the the tables were
labeled and so we had to we had to find
a different way to solve this problem
and let me walk you through the solution
that we came up with
so what we did with this problem is
instead of saying okay we're going to
try to find the entire table
we're going to solve a different problem
which is defined a corner of a table
and the nice thing about the corner
finding the corners is there's many many
cells on a given sheet
and every single one of those cells now
becomes a training example
okay and i'll walk through how we built
the network that does this and but this
will illustrate two things one is it'll
illustrate how we solve this particular
problem but it also illustrates
how all people who build neural networks
have to think about
how you know what their what problem
they're trying to solve and and can they
solve the problem that they're trying to
solve
so first of all you do have to start
with lots of label data in our case we
have thousands of sheets a couple
thousand sheets that we hand labeled
um what we do in all in the case of all
neural networks you have to have a
signal so in our
in our case we looked at the cells and
we built uh
representations of the the contents of
every cell so things like uh what is the
font
you know what is the what is the font
size uh is it underlined you know does
it contain a number
um and so all these different what is
the fill pattern said all these
different characteristics
were labeled for every cell
from that we created an abstraction and
in this particular case we had 51 uh
parameters per cell and and
th the next step is really a learn from
uh image processing the the sort of
building neural networks are on image
processing then we ask the following
question
if we take the the cells around a given
cell like a
like a neighborhood like a 10 by 10
square
can we use all those cells to predict
what the value in the middle is
and and uh how good can we do it that so
what do we mean by the value in the
middle
well what we're trying to do is classify
so for example you see the little
the little rectangle up there we're
trying to classify well what is that
thing in the middle
is it one of the following and here is
the different categories of what we're
trying to classify
is it the top left of it of a table is
it the top right
is it the header bottom left or right
don't worry about the headers
is it the bottom left or the bottom
right or n a which means no this isn't a
corner at all this is this is definitely
not a corner
and so you can see when we give that
input
to our neural network it comes back with
this classification that says hey
the top right is a strong signal here
none of the other ones are very strong
but over over 60 percent if it sinks
that's a top right so
what we said was we're going to change
the problem to be looking for corners
but of course looking for corners is not
the same as finding tables
you actually have to decide what corners
go with each other to actually know
where the table is
and so we have a post-processing phase
which is also the case in many
in many applications of machine learning
where we have to decide we have to
create an algorithm to stitch together
corners
and then we get a table so then we
decide where the whole table is but let
me show you in practice kind of what
this looks like
um this is a similar table to the one i
showed earlier
um and and the colors here now are
meaningful with respect to
what our neural network thinks about
every cell so a dark blue
the darkness indicates how strong the
signal is and the color like blue in
this case
is a signal for a lower left is that no
lower right corner
likewise the pink is a signal for an
upper right corner
so you can see there's you know there's
clearly you know some cells that have a
strong signal
and then other cells which is have a
weaker signal like this this could be
uh you know uh maybe it's a what is a
bottom left header or bottom right
header but the point is it's not very
strong so this is probably more likely
the case
and once we have this as i mentioned
then we have to have a stitching process
that actually decides where the tables
actually are
and in this case it's determined these
are the tables in effect these are the
rows and columns
that form the headers of the table
and that's that's project jura now let
me just
talk a little bit about this problem as
a challenge problem because unlike
some of the existing efforts around
building neural networks
we have an interesting domain in the
sense that we
often neural networks either look at
images or look at text or maybe look at
images and text together
but here we have what we call a
multimodal domain and what do we mean by
that
well first of all there's visual
information which we you know we that's
why we use the convolutional neural
network is to basically understand
you know what what the what the the
spatial relationships are telling us
and what the the choice of fonts etc is
telling us but
on top of that there's natural language
every table contains
text and from the text from the text in
the headers if it says total
you can infer quite a lot about what the
what the cells in that row or columns
should be
and finally there's code and as we
mentioned there are formulas and the
formulas reference other cells
and that code then is also a signal to
tell you
what the intent of the person writing
the code was what things are related to
each other etc
so bringing all these different signals
together into a single
machine learning model and using it to
understand uh spreadsheets
is really a challenge task and uh it's
kind of
forms the core of our approach to
understanding spreadsheets
okay so i'm i'm done with the sort of
discussing our approaches to
understanding spreadsheets building
tools for
users that help them work with
spreadsheets
now i'm going to expand a little bit to
talk more broadly about data
and you know i say spreadsheets but a
lot of the tools that
we're looking at actually are about
reasoning about tables and tables are
wide
way more common even than spreadsheets
so for example you just go on the web
you can se you'll buy thousands of data
sets
that contain you know uh csv files or
pdf etc um you know go to wikipedia
there's thousands of tables in
wikipedia telling you about everything
you want to know um you know who won the
world cup et cetera
um there's you know online there are
millions of pdf documents there's many
many
company reports all of which contain
information you know
information much like the tables we saw
in the spreadsheets and of course
some of these things uh just like in the
spreadsheets are computed
and so uh you know you can ask well is
that is that computation correct did
they make a mistake
and finally um you know we see even more
of this google recently announced
uh building a uh basically a repository
of data sets and an index so you can
very quickly type in search terms and
find
data related to those search terms
so there's a tremendous amount of data
and the argument i'm making is that
the tool you know we can get that data
the question is what are the tools
that help us really uh work with it to
you know to do good things with it and
to do it correctly
um in fact you know this you know
there's a there's an argument you can
make in this case
where data the amount of data in the
world
that's being collected and stored is
increasing increasing dramatically so
this is one
i guess it's a idc uh
report whatever about projecting out to
2025 basically showing the amount of
data in the world it's just
it just increases exponentially right i
mean and
realistically the amount of code that's
being created is is not
exponentially growing um and in fact at
some point in time this is kind of my
joke
that the code will be totally
overwhelmed by the data and so the data
really is everything
uh and the code's important but it's a
tiny fraction of of all the things that
you have to think about
and in fact you know this this was the
focus of um
uh you know article kind of a uh uh
i don't know forward-looking article and
wired about the end of code is you know
are we done writing code and
instead of writing code now are we gonna
do things like i showed you
with with the table detection process
we're going to train models
and and the thing that we use to do most
software with the things that software
does now
are not going to be by handwritten code
but in fact by by training by
collecting data and training models
but when we step back and say well maybe
that's maybe that's not the whole
picture maybe maybe we're still going to
write a lot of code but even if it's a
small part of the future
it's an important part of the future and
we have to think carefully about what
tools those
people using all that data need to to do
it right
and just like we think about what tools
do software engineers need
you know to find bugs do we don't
obviously we don't want to have security
vulnerabilities
we don't want to have you know cases
where the program crashes reliability
issues
in the same way when we build software
that that that leverages machine
learning or ai
we have to think about what data was
used to train that software
and you know are we are we doing the
best we can what are the best
practices around working with that
software
so for example we want to understand
where did the data come from this is a
fundamental question
and of course there are all kinds of
rules about what data you can and can't
use
and we need you know any developer who
incorporates data into
training for for a for a model that
accompanies software
has to basically answer these questions
um there's there's
a lot of concern around building ai
models around the issues of bias
and fairness and which is to say you
know if the data has implicit biases in
it
and we build models from it then those
models themselves will have the same
bias
likewise it's a security problem around
individuals who
intentionally poison data so in that
case you can have a situation where
somebody
knows that you're going to use the data
that they provide for training
and they they intentionally make it make
it bad in some way so it will make your
model performing correctly
of course just having that data becomes
a challenge compared to software
you may have you know 10 megabytes of
code
in a repository but it may be terabytes
of data is used to
to train a model to to uh you know to be
part of that
be part of that software um and so where
how do you do version control on the
terabytes how do you share it etc
um of course privacy is a fundamental
concern uh when you have so much data
you have to worry about you know it
doesn't contain personal information
you know did you make sure that you got
rid of all that or if it does
you know how do you avoid that personal
information somehow leaking into the
model in such a way
that a clever person can then later
extract it so this question about
how much of that training data is
embedded in the model how much it can be
extracted by an adversary it becomes
a a fundamental concern and you know
that's that's got to be part of every
piece of software
now that uses data to build machine
learning models
another concept called data drift which
is to say when we use data to train a
model
and then later we use that model to
predict something how do we know
that the inputs that we get when we're
using it for inference
actually are close to or like the data
that we use to train it
and if there's this drift and it's quite
different then the performance of our
model
will now all of a sudden not be as good
and we have to worry about how do we
maintain
an understanding of that how do we fix
it even the question of like how do you
know once we know that the model's out
of sync
like you know how do we redeploy it what
you know what are the
circumstances under which we can uh you
know
deploy uh improvement of the model and
know that it's going to be a
improvement across the board um
of course you know in the end there's
biases in the input data there's also
biases in the model itself
and so you have to ask questions like
you know is this model
even though it may have 90 accuracy is
it 90 accuracy across
all individuals say if it's doing face
recognition
are there a subclass of individuals for
which it performs poorly
um you have to understand these things
and finally and i think this is again
this is an open space
in the sense of challenges for people
working in this
uh you know on tools is um like what are
the opportunities for adversaries here
like how easy is it to create
adversarial input
um how do you build the software in such
a way that it's robust so that when
people try to
uh you know you know give inputs that it
are intentionally going to give the
wrong answer
you can detect that or you can at least
you know
protect against it so these are all
incredible challenges
you know i re i just hope that the whole
community can embrace these challenges
because
it's such it's going to be uh now an
increasingly a fundamental part of every
software system
so you should step back and say well
wait a minute um you know if these are
all these new problems
maybe software engineering is obsolete
maybe we don't need any of that old
software engineering
everything's about this data and let me
just say look ai fundamentally is still
software
the whole process involves both a
combination as i mentioned with the jura
example a combination of the training
and the model
but also after the model runs you have
to do some other things so in the case
with
the table detection we had to stitch
together the corners
and you know i think you can see this
paralleled in
what microsoft has published now is its
concept of ai principles
which are these are fundamental
principles that are true for ai models
and software that uses ai
but also when you step back you you
realize well these are just things that
you want
all software to have prop that that
property it's not it's not just ai
software it's all software
and fundamentally all the you know
concepts are on uh reliability or
privacy
or transparency are all things that we
have to think about
um across the board both with software
that uses ai and software that doesn't
use ai
so so the answer the answer to is you
know is it obsolete well the answer in
my opinion is no
but here's an even uh sort of more
important point
which is that you know the the stakes
are high
the the kinds of expectations that
people have around building software
um really have grown dramatically
in terms of the kinds of problems the
kinds of uh support that they can give
to humans
the kinds of uh sort of challenges in
the world that
it can help solve and so ed lazowska
has this very nice graphic from you know
five uh five to ten years ago now but
highly relevant still is the notion that
historically
um computer science has really thought
about sort of core issues like
operating systems or databases or
hardware hardware architecture
but but as we look uh you know in the
last 10 years in the last 20 years
the the the sort of impact and the kinds
of things that
computer science has been applied to is
just broadly increasing
so big data is a general category cloud
computing a general category but they're
not
necessarily in the core they're sort of
you know i take operating systems but
then i have to say well how do i deal
with
a hundred thousand computers in the
cloud and you know i want to manage all
of those
um similarly you know nlp is is a is a
is it's part of the core ai but it's a
very specific
problem that even if you solve that one
problem and not the general problem
you have you have a tremendous amount of
impact and beyond
you know these expansions of the core
there are all these different
application areas
for which we now see computers playing a
fundamental role so we're actually
saying now
we can transform all scientific
discovery in
using these new approaches and doing it
with computers is a fundamental part of
that
um same with energy and sustainability
you know if we want to build
a world where we can have sustainable
energy we need to think about how
computers are going to help with that
problem
okay so i'm almost done i appreciate
your patience and time
one of the things i want to say is you
know let's just start with what is a
program like we think about developers
software developers we think about code
that's a program but let me let me try
to expand your view
i'm going to argue that a spreadsheet is
a program i'm going to argue
that a programming by example
illustration of like i want to transform
this thing to that thing
now build a program from that that's
code that's a new kind of code
it's examples instead of instead of you
know if statements
but it's still code and finally you know
the ai model where you have a hundred
thousand images
and you're generating something that
recognizes cats in those images
that's also a new approach to
programming and fundamentally has many
of the same issues that we have always
had with programming
so who is the programmer in this case
well it's certainly not professional
developers it's really a broader set of
people
i call it the grow dev movement where
you have more more people
participating needing the tools uh and
and
and basically trying to leverage these
computers to do
more and more important things so just
to summarize in a very concise way
i think we have to have new tools that
connect non-programmers
in an intuitive way because you know we
really need to think carefully about how
to make it easy
how to avoid having people make mistakes
uh all the things that we want to have
in
in quality software and then we have to
think about understanding both the code
and the data because fundamentally
ignoring the data not understanding what
the data how much impact the data has
will not be a good thing in the future
all right so let me just say um you know
just a final note i really want to push
this notion of broadening the view of
who's a programmer
i want to broaden the view of who needs
these tools and i think
one of the messages here is we need to
get you know if we're if we're in the
software engineering community we need
to get outside the box and start
talking to people that aren't other
coders aren't other programmers
talk to the people working with data
talk to the people who are trying to do
you know science
uh and get get an understanding from
them of how the things that we need
in our software development process
could be broadened
to help them as well so understanding
workflows
uh doing a vertical really understanding
the tasks et cetera
so and i you know let me just
basically emphasize the aspect of human
computer interaction
so in this particular case it's not that
there's just some piece of code that's
syntactically
correct a lot of the the subtleties of
how you work with people and give them
tools
is to understand what their
understanding is what information you're
giving them and how that is going back
and forth to help them solve their
problem
so i think you know this we can't
capture everything mathematically one of
the things about spreadsheets that we've
learned
is that there are aspects of
spreadsheets which are about human to
human communication
and we can't find formal ways to
characterize that we have to actually
use statistics
and and machine learning etc to
understand that and with that i'm done
um i want to thank you uh for your
patience and for your interest
um uh this is my work uh not just my
work it's
it's actually the work of many
individuals uh who who i've worked with
and i've done most of the the heavy
lifting um
if you want to sort of follow some of my
thoughts or insights
i occasionally post to twitter and you
can follow me there um
the the slide that i showed uh from ed
lazowska
um is actually i i got contact with this
uh through an organization called the
ccc which is a computing
uh computing community consortium which
is a group of uh
it's a council that looks at uh patterns
in
computer science research and tries to
help predict future patterns and uh
so i there's a website and they have
lots of interesting material there
about the future of computing uh with
that i thank you
hello everyone thank you so much for
attending the seminar on
the future of data programming it's been
a great pleasure
to present it and i'm happy to answer
some questions
i'm ben zorn i work at microsoft
research in redmond
and um i'm going to be answering
questions over the next 15 minutes
some of the questions that you asked in
the stream and also other questions
that i've had um
so in terms of uh you know some of the
some of the thoughts that we've had
around you know programming with data
i think you know one thought is how many
other kinds of technologies
around uh helping people save with
spreadsheets can you think of
going to go beyond just finding bugs
which is one of the things i mentioned
in the in the talk and you know there
are a number of ways that you can
imagine
helping people you know not just in
spreadsheets but also people working
with any kind of large
data sets um some of those are basically
understanding patterns in the data
and and helping people identify those
patterns
without them explicitly exploring so
data exploration data
the data analysis involves an
exploratory phase often involves
um a human you know trying this trying
that basically experimenting
and you know one of the things we can
understand uh is
you know how to how to accelerate that
process how to bring the human into the
loop
but at the same time uh you know give
them
insights more quickly and so one of the
technologies you know i i didn't mention
in the talk which is actually quite
important
is um you know excel has already
a feature called ideas that where it
appears it's a new panel that appears
that you click on the ideas button
and it will basically show you things
about the data set that you have
in the current sheet that help you
essentially get insights into what's
going on so for example it might suggest
a trend that's in your data it might
suggest
a chart a recommended chart that could
be created from that data
um and so these are things that uh
augment
a person they augment our ability to
understand what
the data represents but at the same time
they give us
uh they accelerate our ability to
quickly see those insights and
and act on them um another dimension of
the kinds of things that people working
with tools
uh face uh you know spreadsheets in
particular is
really managing the whole process around
creating spreadsheets
sharing them updating them et cetera and
in particular
a number of people would get value out
of better tools that help them
understand
where the data in a spreadsheet came
from or if the spreadsheet gets changed
over time
what changes were made and how and who
made the changes and why the changes
were made
and so just as we see in the software
development process where you have code
reviews and you have um you know
powerful um version control
that gives you insights quickly into
sort of why things were done or how
things were done
i think tools around helping people
manage data
that that shares that experience that
allows people to answer questions about
why
or or what was modified or where did
this data come from these are tools that
will benefit
more and more people in the future and
and you know are valuable
um another question um you know
is how do we expect uh
you know these tools uh that developers
use to support
uh data program you know data
programming and one of the things i
you know i in the focus of the talk i
focused on non-developers and sort of
how to give them
a set of capabilities that would uh you
know accelerate their ability to work
with data
but in fact there's also many developers
have a lot more data in their process so
for example as i mentioned
you know many of them are now
incorporating ai models etc
and you know i think we're just learning
how to incorporate
new tools that understand data
understand ai models
into the development process so support
for ai
and machine learning workflows um you
know
is is increasing you get uh you know in
cloud and cloud computing in particular
uh configurations like azure ml give you
tools that help you um incorporate
the kinds of analyses and the kinds of
workflows that
that take data from one source uh
transform it and then feed it into a
machine learning model and and make that
a capability that's quite easy to do
relatively relatively seamlessly
basically by people
connecting things and not necessarily
having to write a lot of code that
opens files et cetera so you can imagine
a
you know a significant improvement in
the ability for people
to very quickly have an entire workflow
and then within that workflow you know a
new capability
as i mentioned in the talk you know it
comes around things like um learning
i mean like fairness so in fact there's
a uh
there's a capability and microsoft
research has released called fair learn
which helps uh people who are involved
in the development of artificial
intelligence assess their systems
fairness
and basically these are the kinds of new
things
that developers have to think about and
tools like fair learn
are a starting point to help them do
that
as you know as organizations get more
experience to understand the process of
ai development
you know i think what we'll see is we'll
see a sort of a progression from
um starting with just an understanding
the right guidelines like what
what do we think about how do we think
about the the challenges
uh then beyond the guidelines and best
practices we'll start seeing them
in body and tools like fair learn that
then allow you to automate part of the
process
another question that came up was how
can people um
you know sort of uh that aren't on a pro
a pro dev sort of a pro education path
take advantage of some of these
capabilities and i think
you know a couple things to mention you
know one of the most important is
that increasingly almost every kind of
major has a component of it that
involves uh
some some capability related to
getting data or understanding data and
so understanding data through statistics
or taking classes in data science that
that introduce you to the tools
as i mentioned you know things like the
the r programming language or the tools
in python
uh the jupiter notebooks etc these are
all capabilities
that allow you to uh get started working
with data relatively easily
um there are many resources on the web
related to understanding
uh how to build notebooks how to
experiment um
with data um and you know and to really
explore the data in you know deeper ways
um
you know the the the existence of many
uh uh python the jupiter notebooks
um and the and the documentation that
goes along with them explaining to
people
you know uh the process and sort of
doing step by step
uh uh there there's many youtube videos
for example that help
you walk through how to use tool sets to
give you this kind of capability
as a final question you know i think one
of the things that you know i hear
a lot is people asking sort of you know
where we are now
like what will programming be like in 10
years and you know
uh if you think about 10 years ago you
know well people were writing code but
i think a lot more people now are doing
things as i mentioned like training
machine learning models there's a lot
more data science it's really
become a major part of the computer the
computer field
and you know i think as i mentioned in
the talk one of the most important
aspects of the future is going to be
the degree to which uh data is an
integral part i think you know we we
have a question about how we
uh how we share that data i do think
that you know increasingly
we're seeing more and more data
available um and
uh you know the ability to combine the
data in new ways
and to mash up data in different ways to
really see
and understand things beyond
correlations one of the challenges in
understanding
data is understanding the difference
between causation and correlation
and fundamentally if we can find better
strategies to understand causality to
say
you know the reason that we observe this
correlation is because this
is a cause that that achieves that
effect those kind of tools that help you
tell the difference between uh
correlation causation
um will actually uh i think be very
valuable and uh
increasingly available in the future um
certainly we're going to see
significantly higher ambition we
definitely have a
a huge opportunity in this space to
think about problems that we never were
able to solve in the past
and i i you know i think uh if i could
tell you what
what the most exciting areas in that
space would be um
you know uh i would be uh you know i
would be able to uh
take advantage of that but i just have
to say i think ultimately
um you know the opportunity to make the
tools and the data available
to so many people is really guarantees
an amazing
amount of innovation and new new
discoveries
new applications that we just don't you
know can't even think of right now
um yeah so the ability of
non-programmers
and individuals to take advantage of
this data both
in terms of doing analysis understanding
causation etc
and also of being able to um you know
construct ai models
i i do believe that in the future uh the
ability to you know to get labeled data
and to use unsupervised learning etc to
create models for non-uh experts will
become
more more important and i think we're
just at the beginning of understanding
how to do that well um
yeah so with that i'd like to thank you
so much for attending
um it's been a real pleasure to talk
about my work and the
the great opportunities that are
available um
if you're interested in learning more we
we have resources on the resource list
on the screen and um certainly uh
i encourage you to uh you know if you're
if you use excel and you're interested
in um
trying out excellent um i definitely
encourage you to go to the website and
and check that out um and overall
i definitely encourage you to uh you
know engage with uh resources on the web
related to
uh you know using tools that exist in in
terms of our
our notebooks i mean i'm sorry our
studio and
python notebooks to really explore data
and to learn how to manipulate it and to
extract ideas from it uh more
effectively
so thank you and have a great day